so i hump this danish chick and i get  done as i used to do with my condom i  took it off hide it in a knot twirl it  around and i threw it on the floor i  went outside i'm smoking a cigarette and  i see the dog just running into the room  then when i walk into the room [ __ ]  condoms not on the floor anymore  possibility was the dog swallowing the  condom and it getting wrapped up in its  intestines and killing the dog so i'm  freaking out and for the next few days  i'm just doing drugs staying awake and  just trying to follow this [ __ ] dog  around  i ended up passing out when i woke up i  found this one log of dog poop just  morphed into the actual condom it's  totally still intact i pinched the ring  of the condom and lifted up and the  piece of dog food was just sticking out  sideways and the whole condom with the  load fully intact  if you think about it i sort of  sodomized the dog  [Music]